and I do wonder you know why why
wouldn't it be possible to have a
technological input unless it might be
that you know there's something about
meditation what's the first step in many
meditations it's gonna close your eyes
but then you have these other
technologies like the oculus you know VR
headsets you know and you don't get into
this too much but you you know it was
kind of written I think a little bit
before the onslaught of AR and VR but is
there a place for it I mean can I
imagine having a muse headband with
goggles with ears with ear and then tiny
haptic electric shocks you know if I
stop think you know like we need some
negative reinforcement - it can only be
positive right I so I think that's a I
think it's a technology absolutely plays
a role and we you know we people can see
from the Anderson Cooper video there is
you know we're using we're already
starting to move from fMRI to eg
neurofeedback where we can get specific
signal from people deep in people's
brains which wasn't possible ten years
ago and we're even moving from hundred
twenty eight leads down to 32 leads or
so so I think the technology is
improving rapidly enough that we can see
you know we're gonna see this thing
happen you know in the next couple of
years and I and we've done a bunch of
studies specifically to map out these
different brain regions and how they
line up with meditation all this we
published a bunch of papers on it so the
idea is can we get a technology that
really does line up with the elements of
meditation and also importantly I think
feedback is only good if it can teach us
something about ourselves so we can
we're not dependent on the technology so
I think technology is a great way to
teach us something but if we become
dependent on Punnett is that really
decorated of a thing
[Music]